I'm Kyle kirwan I'm the CEO of big eye
before bigeye I worked on the data
platform team at Uber for several years
so I was a product manager there I was a
data scientist before that and I led a
team there of about 15 and we built a
bunch of internal tools for uh doing
data quality testing for uh doing
Incident Management for data pipelines
we developed a data catalog internally a
data lineage system and these were super
super useful in the context of Incident
Management for preventing problems from
reaching our actual business so we were
doing things like ETA predictions
Dynamic pricing if you ever submit a
support ticket in the Uber app that's
actually hitting a model first to decide
whether or not that support ticket needs
to go to a human for a response or it
may actually go and skip over one level
of human and go directly to somebody who
has the ability to issue refunds without
asking for permission and stuff like
that so a ton of the edge of Uber's
business between their company and you
is driven by uh sort of online things
that depend on data pipelines and so
being able to identify when we had a
problem in a pipeline and importantly do
something about it in an organized
fashion was super important there and
that led to me eventually leaving and
starting to work on big eye this talk is
not about big eye though this talk is
about instant management so what is
Incident Management so the ITIL which is
a service that or it's a group or
Foundation that defines a lot of stuff
around it Services defines it as an
unplanned Interruption to a service or a
reduction in quality of a service and if
that sounds a little bit dry I brought a
picture
so that's you on the right if you're a
data engineer and this is your users on
the left and this would be what an
incident looks like and so this is what
they look like at Uber right so we would
have a problem in a data pipeline
somewhere it would Cascade down that
pipeline it get into a query it'd go
into a dashboard and then some executive
is looking at that dashboard and they're
like why is there no data in here for
three days or this number is obviously
incred correct like sales did not triple
last week for the entire planet I'm
pretty sure and so then they would get
upset and then that would go to the head
of data and then that would go to
somebody else and then eventually that
would go to me or somebody on my team or
another data engineer and then they have
a very bad day
um so the good news is uh Incident
Management as a concept for dealing with
these types of problems in an organized
fashion has actually been around for
quite a while just not in most data
teams so Incident Management is largely
practiced in software engineering devops
infrastructure and there's a number of
very very large companies out there that
among other things make Incident
Management Systems so atlassian if
anybody's used jira before I too love
jira and atlassian makes Incident
Management stuff fire hydrant to the
right of that is a younger company but
they focus on Incident Management of
course everybody knows datadog and
pagerduty as well I'm sure and so this
is a very well fleshed out process
traditionally in devops and software
engineering um so this talk is about
explaining just these Core Concepts and
fundamentals that have been used for
over a decade to help software and
devops teams deal with these problems in
an efficient manner and get them fixed
before they cause Major Impact
businesses so I'm going to walk you
through that
so this is the basic flow of an incident
management process so from top to bottom
the first step is identification so this
is figuring out that something is broken
in the first place so ideally this is
done with monitoring and alerting
systems on a lot of data teams it's done
by people looking at the dashboards that
are busted so that's a problem in and of
itself but that is where the incident
begins is in realizing something's wrong
the second step is in mobilizing a team
of people that are going to go and do
something about it so this is sending
out Pages this is pulling together
people in slack Etc we'll talk about
what that team looks like in a bit the
next step is diagnosis so that team
comes together they look at what is the
actual impact from the problem how many
of our customers does this affect if any
they escalate the problem and say well
this is not really a big deal like we'll
fix it but it doesn't need to happen
right now or let's start pulling people
in this is costing ten thousand dollars
every 15 minutes that we don't solve the
problem we need to move like right now
so that happens at the diagnosis phase
then there's the resolution solution
phase where we actually do something to
fix the issue this could be working in
you know doing an airflow backflow or a
backfill or something like that and then
closure happens quite a bit afterwards
but this is wrapping up what happened
and looking for things that we can do
better next time
so stepping through that identification
phase so on the left I mentioned uh
datadog is one of these like tools
that's been around for a decade on the
software and infrastructure side so in
an ideal case your tools are doing the
identification of a problem for you this
could happen at three in the morning so
for example here we have a spike in API
endpoint latency this could happen at
3am your software engineering team might
be asleep your devops team might be
asleep so this needs to be picked up by
a machine you can't sit around and wait
for a human being to say oh you know if
you work at Google and you're an SRE at
Google you can't just have people at
Google go load the home page and see if
the home page is loading slowly you need
you know automated alerting to tell you
about this on the right is an example in
a data context so this is a screenshot
from our product identifying a drop in
the number of rows inserted into a table
in Snowflake either way you should be
alerting on these types of things in an
automated fashion so that machines can
pick up problems before humans do
next up mobilization so I mentioned
pulling a team together so there's a few
key roles in a standard Incident
Management process they can vary a
little bit from company to company but a
very common template is an Incident
Commander this is the person who's
making decisions about what the team's
going to do next who do we need to pull
in ETC so they're helping guide the
process of solving the problem you have
somebody that's called a scribe I think
this is a funny name but it's apt so
this person's pure job is to document
everything that's happening they don't
need to make decisions they don't need
to communicate externally with anybody
they don't need to do any debugging
they're documenting absolutely
everything that's happening during the
incident so if there's a clear record of
what happened afterwards
a liaison focuses on external
communication often the manager of the
team is not The Incident Commander often
the liaison is the manager of a team and
they're the one who is communicating
upward to the rest of the organization
they're telling leadership what's going
on they might be communicating
externally with customers and they'll be
providing updates on a regular basis
saying we've identified the source of
the problem we're taking steps to
resolve it we haven't resolved it yet
four hours later okay the problem's
resolved this is what we're doing to
clean it up very often that's the the
team leader the manager and then you've
got your subject matter experts so these
in a data team might be analytics
Engineers data Engineers data scientists
and these are the people who actually
have an intimate knowledge of the
pipeline the data set the various tools
that are used and they can actually go
in and perform fixes and solutions and
get Hands-On keyboard importantly you'll
notice that each person has a role and
those roles don't overlap and this is a
really key part of being prepared for
Incident Management is that when that
team comes together even if it's three
in the morning and everybody's groggy
because they just woke up everybody
knows what they're supposed to do and
there's no confusion and so balls don't
get dropped because people aren't
forgetting to scribe and take notes
because somebody's explicit job is to be
described
okay next step diagnosis um so an
important thing that happens in this
stage is our team needs to understand
what is the impact of the problem that's
happening and a very common uh
escalation pattern that's used for this
is called sevs so starting from the
bottom a sub five problem is something
that goes in your backlog or it's
something that you fix next week it's a
very minor issue it definitely does not
hurt your users or your business in any
way it doesn't take down any internal
Services as we work our way to the top
we have a larger amount of degradation
of our internal services and we have a
larger impact to our customer base so at
Uber anything that would prevent you
from actually taking a trip or anything
that dramatically spiked or dropped a
dynamic price that caused you not to not
to request a trip that would have been a
Sev five outage because at their scale
that can easily cost millions of dollars
over the span of like an hour given the
size of business that they're operating
this would also be true at a meta or
Google or anybody else as well
um so what you the team's going to do
during this diagnosis phase is escalate
the issue up as high as it needs to go
and no further and then they'll they'll
be able to pull in resources from other
teams if needed take extra actions as
needed or if they discover it's actually
a lower level problem then everybody can
go back to sleep we'll put it in the in
the ticketing system and we'll deal with
it tomorrow
Okay resolution so we've got our team
they're taking actions during the
diagnosis step we also identified why is
the problem occurring we used our
observability we used our monitoring
systems we dug into the issue now it's
time to actually go and get Hands-On
keyboard and implement the fixes so as I
mentioned in a data context this might
mean rolling back a change to a DBT
model and then re-running the job to
backfill a table it might be you know
restarting an airflow task but whatever
those steps are that you identified in
the diagnosis phase now you're actually
doing them and you may be sitting around
waiting for those steps to complete
right it may take a while for that
backfill to run depending on the size of
your data set but all of that work is
captured in this resolution phase
this also includes capping It Off by
confirming that the fixes have worked so
it's really important that you
re-evaluate whatever your pipeline or
your services from the perspective of
your users and make sure that okay now
the data all does look correct they're
ready to use it again and we're we're
sort of done with that phase
last phase closure so this happens
afterwards and this is just the team
wrapping up and identifying what steps
could we have taken to prevent the
problem what could we do better next
time that gets documented importantly
this is a called a blameless process so
we're not looking for whose fault is it
that the problem occurred that's a No-No
topic the only focus is on why did it
happen What systems broke what could we
do better next time
uh if you want to learn more about this
topic those four tools that I
recommended have a ton of great
materials on their blogs they have
playbooks they have guides a lot of the
material here you can find in various
ebooks and things like that and start to
put into practice on your own team I
didn't link to them here they're pretty
easy to find on their websites but if
you do want links please send me a note
and I'd be happy to send you some of
them later thanks for learning about
Incident Management
[Music]